The people most affected by the negative aspects of it are the poor and the powerless – which in America,
by and far, are the people of color, are black people.
1,500 feet. Right beyond those trees is the plant.
How far away is this elementary school from the plant?
being bombarded with that, some of them, 24 hours a day.
still a majority-black school today. The
school has levels of chloroprene that are
A large percentage of these students live right here as well, so these kids are
400 times higher than what the EPA says
is safe to breathe.
Robert went to school here in the late
50's, early 60's, during segregation. It's
This school is a big point of contention.
We have the Fifth Ward School right there, with the lower elementary being really, really exposed.
Yes. It is totally undeniable that the link is there.
In your opinion, is it undeniable that it's linked [to cancer]?
well as leukemia, heart and reproductive problems.
absorbed through the skin, and is linked
to liver, kidney, and digestive cancers, as
pungent smell. The chemical enters the
body when it's breathed in, ingested or
Chloroprene is released into the air during its production process. It can't be seen, but does give off a
This is the only community exposed to chloroprene at these high concentrations in the whole United States.
DuPont operated the plant until Denka took it over in 2015, keeping on almost all of the facility's employees.
LaPlace-Reserve area for 49 years, and
releasing it into the air.
Everybody's been exposed for a very, very long time. DuPont has been making chloroprene here in
They hold regular meetings to fill the
town in on what's going on.
Robert teamed up with Wilma Subra, a chemist who is doing pro bono scientific analysis for the community.
look what I've got to go through. Look what I'm up against, just trying to come and visit with them.
My mom and my dad in there. Brothers and sisters, uncles, aunts, my grandfather, but
with Robert. Petrochemical companies on
all of the surrounding land.
This is the cemetery. Across
the tracks, this is where I was standing
I have to visit from here. I can’t go on that property, I can’t even walk across to go into the cemetery.
So you have to visit from here?
relatives, who mostly died of cancers
linked to the emissions.
All of our ancestors here now are covered by this monstrosity here.
neighborhood now is this cemetery, which
is ironically filled with Robert's
Mississippi River, highways and railroads.
All that's left of Robert's childhood
companies have bought out much of the
town because of its proximity to the
sugarcane fields. The sugar company
closed in 1985, and now petrochemical
Reserve was once a thriving black community post-World War II. Robert's parents and many others were
drawn to work in the large sugar
refinery or farming the surrounding
we're still deep in slavery in America.
The methodologies and whatnot changed, but the effect and all of this is still the same,
that the powers that be have toward black
people has not changed since slavery.
We don't even have a swimming pool in the black community. The predatory attitude
in wetsuits and laptop covers. It's more
of a product that's made for people's recreation.
Well, that's a that's a part
of that humiliation that we suffer.
which makes chloroprene, a chemical the
EPA says is a likely carcinogen.
I think the ignitions need to stop. I don't think that human life should be subject to a profit motive.
What chloroprene goes to
make is the neoprene material that goes
large chemical plant a few blocks from
his house. It's the only plant in the U.S.
He's currently in a legal battle against a
it was a next-door neighbor and the people down the street.
son died of lung cancer. My wife got it.  My daughter. When it wasn't close relatives,
Robert Taylor has lived here all his
life. And he's surprised he's made it to the age of 77.
My mother got cancer. My
brother died of lung cancer. My sister's
poor and black, with extremely high rates
of sickness and suffering.
We're in what's known as Cancer Alley in Louisiana, an area between New Orleans and Baton Rouge
But we know that people in this little
town are suffering at a cancer rate
lined with petrochemical plants and
refineries. Most of the towns here are
that's 700 to 800 times that of the nation.
Welcome to Reserve, Louisiana. This is
the cancer capital of the United States.
cancer and realize the suffering that they're going through. And to realize that you could be next.
that’s where our power will be. We’ll exercise political power. That’s where our hope lies.
What I get from them since I’ve been involved is just a sense of helplessness, powerlessness. How can we
Something is here, killing us. It's a
terrible thing to watch people die of
fight these powerful, rich organizations? Once we can get enough people to join with us,